Welcome to talk to actually get off first.
It's tough in the air and delighted to introduce our PR group.
Morning,
how are you my book?
As you can see behind the smoke 10 right?
Positives to promote your business.
Basically it's gears to people in the small to medium size enterprises.
It's really teaching them how to promote their business by using PR tunes.
So all of the tools in the RP or tools I thought I'm like again by trying to get
us to agree on what PR actually is.
An awful lot of people think bureaus free advertising,
you don't remove it.
You know advertising gives them free
advertising,
you buy the space,
you've put something in and and the purpose of advertising is to sell a product
so it works and what doesn't work on the basis of how much product did you
shift?
It's very easy to analyze.
Public Relations on the other hand creates stories.
It tells you who people are and what they do and why the passion about the
business and why you should actually invest in them.
I often think public relations people are like,
I like doctors cause they work from a goodie bag with a goody bag,
has loads of tools and you go to a doctor and you have a cough.
The Dr. May say,
do you mark?
Is it then it's no big deal.
You need a cough bottle.
The doctor weighed equally look at you and say,
Oh okay,
I need you to get x rays.
Last time I heard somebody in the contract that I never saw them a second time
or the Dr. May way I look at you and say,
you run the,
or there's nothing wrong with you,
go back to work.
I'm not getting you a certificate.
But he dips into a Gucci bag of tools and says,
here's what you need your people to do exactly the same thing.
So we look at a business and we say,
okay,
if you were trying to communicate with people,
which tool do you need to use?
So should you be using exhibitions?
Is An easy,
should you be using social media?
Should you be using,
um,
sponsorship?
What's the tool that would work best for each different audience?
Cause you won't reach everybody you can say too.
So this book is about 10 of the tools that I believe are most relevant to people
in SMEs.
Before I move on to the money for that.
You mentioned the word spin because every time you hear the word public
relations,
you hear spin on PR.
People have this huge thing about when we do not spend,
we are not spin.
Doctors were in public relations.
I was introduced to by two,
three or four years ago as the princess of the dark art of spin.
I absolutely adored.
I am dying though ever since because I think that is exactly what we do is do
it.
People do.
I wore a suit this morning.
I'm serious about being an Auger.
I spit.
I could've come in in a pair of jeans.
You would've had an entirely different visions,
visual spin.
You chose to dress exactly the way you chose this morning because it says
something about you,
the mood you're in.
Why don't you want to project to people in the world today.
That's been,
that's a visual spin.
We also do it by sort of two ways it has been.
One is visually.
So what you look at says something about it creates an expectation,
but equally texts does the same thing.
Let me give you an example.
If I said that my best friend,
okay,
is a drug addict,
what immediately comes into your head or just drug addicts said,
Phil's takes drugs.
That Domino's not really the best and probably in a bad place right now,
uh,
needs to feed the habit.
So God only knows how they actually get enough money to feed the habit.
The whole drug addicts,
just the use of boards.
Drug addict says,
hmm,
I wouldn't have thought she had,
she associated with those kinds of people.
If on the other hand,
I said,
my best friend is a recreational user.
You Go,
whoa.
Too many parties,
we're gonna come back and that stuff,
it'll kill your venture.
You some hold different spin.
You're still talking about somebody who uses drugs,
but it's the spin.
It's a text who will spin your head,
creates a different picture.
And that's what PR people do.
And they say,
don't look over there.
Look over here.
That's what's been is about,
it's not about telling a lie,
it's about diverting your attention just a little bit.
So visualist fit.
Let me go get four off the 10 rent hot tips possibly that are included in this
book.
Visual phobic calls,
and we live in a visual.
It looks at the way we watch news and the way news is presented to us how it's
changed in the last 10 or 15 years.
If you don't do news years ago,
it was one person sitting to a camera on television saying,
here is the news,
and you had a kid behind.
If you watch news on television,
now you've got all of these boxes coming down the side with short and breaking.
This is abused.
You've got ticker tape running underneath.
Nobody actually sits there and waits for the next story.
We have no patients of the visual tells us something.
It's like,
I've seen,
um,
this morning who was an avalanche initially,
I've seen the avalanche.
I know what happened.
It's a visual kind of thing.
If you can create a really good visual,
people will remember they associated with your business and there are two ways
to do it with,
one is by phone call and one is by photo shoot.
Photo call is where you actually invited all of the media to attend and you set
up the picture from photo shoots where you create the photograph and you send it
to the media.
So let me give you an example of,
oh we did a phone,
I must warn you in advance.
Small liquor people vertically challenged,
generally called children.
I don't have any of them.
I find that fairly dense
text.
You realize this story.
So I regard them with very few challenged until they're my hype and make eye
contact and speak and 40 form sentences.
They're like,
nice to meet you,
good to move on.
So I'm doing this photo call on them.
It's for the opening of a school,
it's against goal.
And I have two children photographer sitting beside me and he says,
okay,
what I want to get is that traditional shop.
I want to get a little boy,
little girl holding hands walking at school.
They want to come easy.
I told you I've no kids,
so I just want me to,
that there's a void there that we keep around there.
So yeah,
they were patching.
Nice.
Shawn,
do me a favorite home Morin's time pays.
Yeah.
Maureen hold Sean's handpiece
and she puts her hand and he goes,
I'm not Julie.
Hey,
we go through this about two or three times.
I said,
jobs like this kid has an attitude problem.
He said,
no,
we're not going to get the shot.
I said,
no,
we got the shop.
I just need to lose charge.
Okay.
So without even thinking of a,
but now I'm in the zone,
so I've heard about the said who wants to do the board talk with turns back to
me and went owns [inaudible] going to record this.
I'm filling,
somebody's just going to a child and this father can
and
I still have with reading register.
Fuck.
The photographer said.
So I said,
wait,
do me and say,
what do you just talk for is trying to get a shot to the Irish times,
the Kimble cooperate.
I just wanted to hold her.
You won't do it.
Sorry that that kid had his chance.
He's gone.
I need,
I don't do tactical library.
What was the focus reaction?
Any idea
to
hold hands
because all the Irish times he didn't hear that you guys would be going to
cooperative.
He didn't hear who owns the trailer.
He heard Irish times and my child and we got the front page of the Irish Times
the next day with the child.
It was a classic sharp pinch.
The charge you put the sender's look better
from the food's going to do what they want.
The,
they were looking for a bit of publicity to said the school has opened.
It's a new school,
it's in this area.
I love the ends of the Earth was front page of the Irish Times with the shop and
said this is the new school that opened and it was outside of buildup and so the
chances of actually getting that kind of publicity,
but it was a great photograph.
So you take a great shop,
people will look at it and they remembered example that I used in the book who
was from Butler's pantry.
You're familiar with lockers.
Pantry pantry is,
um,
probably the best,
kind of like a gourmet food outlet,
you call it there if you want to buy really good quality,
fresh homemade food on the way home,
the,
the kind of like marks and Spencer's do those Google ads in other way.
You put in from change,
he'd eaten an entire meeting and you're stuffed.
I'm thinking I never want to see food again.
And a marks and Spencers food that comes on.
You Go Alex Levine
food.
If you're going to promote food,
you have to promote food with that yogis and Butler's pantry bring in a
professional photographer each time they take photographs.
But because photography is so,
and it's probably only about half the price that it was five or six years ago,
five or six years ago,
you brought him before then the crash,
if you brought him in photographer to do any photo shoot,
you says the client,
you need 1200 to 1500,
you won't get out.
You don't get changed.
And now you're looking at somewhere around three to 600.
So it's a big change.
But for a small business,
you're still looking at and bringing in a photographer to take a photograph.
And I don't know if anybody would be used it.
So I have a really good quality photograph,
but will it be used?
I'm a Butler's pantry doing this.
They trial all the photographs.
So what they're doing in you,
I don't know,
Salmon dish,
they story board the entire thing.
So this is how we would like to promote salmon.
This is what we want people to think and feel when we say salmon sound.
That sounded like [inaudible] time,
fresh fish or just sound of knowledge,
whatever it is.
And then we're trying to create the photograph.
So they spent days seeing what works best.
Should I put this here?
Should I put that there?
Um,
how exactly do we make the people,
the groups together and when they think they have an exactly right then began as
a photographer,
it and photographer literally shoots or the photographs that they take have been
used for up to five years,
which is a very long time to get under the photo.
But it's good value.
But their attitude is they spend that much money.
They really want to be sure before the photographer comes in the door as giving
the message that they wanted to.
And that's a visual message and that's public relations.
That's a phone call.
The second area wants to look at a sponsorship because people seem to think that
sponsorship is all about how we to money.
Everybody knows the big sponsorships because during your face then a huge
budgets behind them.
Sponsorship can work really,
really well for small to medium size enterprise,
but it only works really well if like everything else you do,
like you put time into it and you think it true.
So let me give you two examples of sponsorship.
One Golden,
one bad example I use in the book was company called Action Coach action called
to work with small to medium size enterprises.
And their job is that they basically they go into companies and they teach them
how to be more competitive.
So that may be how to take risks in certain markets.
So they may say to them,
look,
if you're are targeting to target your market as far too broad,
you're never going to reach everybody.
You need to try a little bit tighter or maybe that you just don't know what
you're doing in terms of money.
So we need to actually teach you a little bit more about profit and loss of how
to manage money and how to look after passional and basically they work with
small businesses trying to get them to the next step.
They're based in valley model and they're very passionate about being a valuable
and what can they do for people.
Invaluable.
And there's,
I'm going to be shocked,
there's a rugby player,
I hope it's on sports,
who's from Ballymun there.
There'd be no compliment anyway or we could be complex.
Anyway,
this guy is a very good non sport person from value and they met him at the top
on it.
Literally they were just sitting,
listening to him talking and he was talking about the fact that he come from
Valley Mountain.
His family were very poor.
He done very well.
He was looking to give something back to the area and it started them thinking
and they developed a board game and the board game teaches you how to do with
profit loss.
How do you look after cashflow house,
take risks and to analyze risks.
And they decided to,
what they would do is they would work with local schools and they would go into
the local schools and create a competition,
but teach children how to,
how to build up the skills.
And the objective was two fold.
One was that they might actually find that they've been interested in commerce
or becoming off for nerds are running their own businesses.
But the second was that if they never did,
they have developed skills which are useful for the rest of their lives.
And that's a leaflet example,
a sponsorship.
Another example is are by comparison you're in what we all call Google Lounge
now,
but I used to live around the corner of exact road.
Um,
so I don't know whether you should move out.
Me Mean to go down there.
I should be thanking you for inviting me back home again.
But I've lived on rings road that was very involved in the community and
[inaudible] cause I was there,
I lived there all my life.
I got married,
moved away,
came back to live there when I was married and we moved down to about 15 years
ago.
And I just,
I love being involved in community and cause I think it's who we are.
We don't have enough community involvement whether it's community of interest or
physical community in which we did.
We had a guy,
Morris County competition by few years ago and the governor's counting
competition was sponsored by the local beauticians,
which I thought was a really nice fixes.
It was clever.
The numbers,
Connie's all came in and they ranged in age at that time.
I'm going back probably 20 years from like 55 to 75 now.
The danger range in age from 35 to 75 but they,
they range in age from about 55 75 so most of the ladies came in and they have
lovely at break off tear that looked like it.
Just taking the car.
There's actually no that you don't have to look at.
The people have and they came up when they sign it.
They talked about like their,
their treat children,
other two grandchildren on how old they were.
A hotter names were very nice,
very pleasant evening.
All of the hospitals by the way,
who were alive came in and still only chemists about purpose.
I came in and stood at the end of the hall,
Watch Charlotte that's [inaudible] and it looked safe for the rest of their
life,
but they did their bit.
They did re web and the beauticians was giving a prize for whatever it was,
200 euros worth of goods in the beauticians they sent in a young mother to
present the products.
So you've got a room full of people who are 55 75 years of age,
all famous and they sent in this absolutely drop dead gorgeous girl.
She was tall,
she was sticking and set Penn.
She was on this hike where he's teetering on Jimmy Choo's.
She won't be able to be models do they kind of off like cats on high heels.
She stretched herself all the way up to the stage.
She looked amazing.
She came up or to present to go up the prices and what everybody did in the
audience as you all pass to say,
oh my God,
look at the height of those seeds.
Can you remember everywhere is that high?
Oh,
Yammer was before I had my first child.
Never worn high.
He a high sense of no cash.
Our NICU weights,
she's a sizing.
I'd say she's a size 10 I was never a sized at the smallest idea for us was 12
actually what they did was they reminded people of what it was like to be on or
single or before they had children.
They brought them back to their twenties they did not target them as 55 to 75
year olds.
What they should have done was they should have got somebody who was either very
well known in the community who was at that age or the previous winter,
the last year and brought her in and hopper so that somebody in their sixties or
seventies presented the prize.
And instead of saying,
look at her waist and do you remember those high years?
You would actually say,
why?
Oh because have a change I've heard or some shit up
because it's then reminded to keep live,
makes the association with people and not to,
my idea was a good,
a very good sponsorship.
They actually,
they miss fires,
they sponsored it,
they put the money into it.
They sent somebody entered,
cause I had the prizes I death fit anybody even connected the two.
It's not about selling,
but I doubt that anyone who walked past and said that's the beauticians and
sponsored because it didn't make that connection.
So sponsorship,
very little money.
And the other thing with sponsorship,
just as I think of when we will package resent,
we moved back after all time.
I grown up and lived there till I was about 18 and I moved back about probably
25 years ago.
I want to move back.
They were still did everything go to the door.
Um,
but I what everybody calls her [inaudible] diary in the morning and our back
late in the evening.
I look for when you're in centers,
always have the wrong pronunciation and everything.
Job Dinners,
do it as a general rule.
So I was done early in the day and literally it does the same story,
but outside the door in the morning got off about saying there's no milk or you
can help maybe,
hey,
we'd have milk today.
And it drove me insane.
So at one stage I'm going to one of the neighbors and said from do me a favor,
if you see the middle plan,
find out what I own,
pay him off.
Tom,
thanks very much.
Um,
and I just get to know sort of as I needed.
And she said [inaudible] [inaudible] that's the problem with a hooker kid.
There's no problem with them.
It's just that they're so amazing.
It's not there other days and no,
I save as like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
we're not going to like you.
You know,
we don't all eat in the middle of the night,
come back from the middle of the night.
That poor man gets off at four o'clock in the morning to deliver the milk.
Nobody should be getting about half three.
It just,
I don't get the milk outside the door.
She got up.
I tell you what I do when I'm passing by it.
There's milk outside your door in the morning.
Take and I'll put it into the shop and I think it called for you and it would
collect it from the shop in the evening.
And I said,
just think about this.
This is not logical.
Each of circumvention these me,
the milk,
you combine all of those committees because I've already integrated out to the
shop.
This is crazy.
Just pay the guy off and tell me how much I old and he said,
she said,
no,
you don't understand.
This man goes out of his way.
He's been producing milk delivery within this area for years and years and he
goes out of his way to sponsor the local soccer club every year.
He buys him a whole set of jerseys.
I thought it was a brilliant example of somebody who like connectors to the
community.
I wasn't connected.
I didn't have kids I didn't respect for this man was doing well.
She did.
I'm an old communities again and that's why we buy our milk from the mine has to
earn a living and he's very good at,
he doesn't have to buy these tee shirts and a really broke homeless sponsorship
and has such a long term impact on people around you.
That mom was getting business because people were brought in.
Parents or people like me who have no kids were totaled.
He's earning his living.
He's contributing to the community.
So good sponsorships,
well,
I don't know,
a lot of constant session jerseys for football team,
but he dumped the return the year on year,
on year on year.
So sponsorship.
The second one,
third one is exhibitions.
The number of people who don't use exhibitions,
property exhibitions you're going to pay to attend.
It's for you decided as a business that this is where you should be.
But the number of businesses who don't then fold.
True.
If you book an exhibition and you hope it already,
if you know in January they should do an exhibition in September,
what happens is that people send you out all of these,
no,
the exhibition organizers,
central hypnosis and say,
so when you be doing anything different at the exhibition,
are you launching anything extraordinary?
Do you have any unusual guests?
Is there anything you want to tell us about your time that makes it different?
Um,
small to medium size enterprises because they're busy look at it and go for
about say,
how do I know in January we've got to go to in September so we need it just told
you one side,
say I'll do it later and then come August.
I say that all the information and whoever was organizing has already decided
who gets the publicity because in January or February,
the organizer was saying,
I need to know where my stories are coming from.
So if you take the trouble to tell me that you're doing something different and
promote you,
so it's freaky or that's sitting there waiting for them.
But people don't actually take advantage of because they need to move.
So maturity there and really if they did,
they have a whole team of professional people promoting them.
It's a no brainer.
It should make sense.
I was at an exhibition for Tyee students,
students and teachers last year,
just before the book came out.
And it was a company called high rock productions who would take in an
exhibition standard.
And the exhibition is huge,
isn't this massive warehouse in one part of them and it's through our house and
every single stand had something for transition year students.
So you had learned your client going to look funny.
Greeks.
Um,
we teach you how to make presentation skills,
come kayaking with else,
um,
whole load of who we teach you first aid.
Ho makes up between kind of skills that you would use as an individual and
things did you went out and did as groups and this particular group,
Hi rob productions,
I stopped you because when I came around the corner who was an entire square
closed off that what they actually do is they go into schools and they help
children's speak Irish.
So they prepped them for the oral Irish six hours,
but they do it by creating this plane.
So it's very creative.
They work with the children,
they create this play and when they've made this play to help them put it all,
it's all through ours.
So they become more confident about speaking divers.
Very hard thing to promote to.
Most of them probably have an interest in like or liars,
that's exams and they're looking at Tyee,
which just a year in between their exams.
So they're not focusing on,
I'm like this group had done was they had taken a square,
they had about three times the amount of space that they should have had it.
So the taking a square in front of the style,
but they closed it off and they were playing virtual tellers.
It was absolutely brilliant because one of the guys were there and you're
saying,
okay,
are you ready to serve you?
Step off the court please.
Your honor.
The court,
you don't have to go.
And as people walk past great here.
Oh sorry.
Sorry.
Am I,
am I okay?
And everybody thought there was nothing.
There was absolutely nothing,
but everybody got,
can we still back?
I went the ball where there's a play.
There was a,
sorry,
can I have the ball there?
Yeah.
Nope,
nope.
At your other phones there.
Yeah.
Can you show it?
Oh,
and everybody stopped to watch.
It was brilliant in took a huge imagine attention to their son and they gave
everybody leaflets.
It's about what they did.
I thought it was [inaudible] reach out when I interviewed them afterwards.
I said to him,
by the way,
brilliant idea you took over.
So spaceless five and this year,
but I'm not sure if it was a smart as it could have been because a targeted all
of the children and their query was the exhibition was targeted to both children
and teachers and with hindsight they weren't sure if you could target boats in
one exhibition and what they had done was they had successfully got all of the
children with children in the side of it.
We'll and t y years teachers did,
so they'd actually think vagueness card.
They got loads of attention.
They've loads of kids talking about it,
but they didn't have the teachers saying what a good idea and people didn't
connect virtual tennis with what they were actually doing.
It was interesting because to my eyes coming in as an outsider,
I talk to very smart like you've,
you've captured the whole room.
When they analyze it afterwards they thought good but not as brilliant as it
could have been.
I suppose one of the things that I'm really conscious of,
the key ares that it's not,
it's not rocket science.
It does take a lot of time,
but most of the scales can be easily learned,
but it's about not doing things on the flight and cause we artists respond.
Whereas things that are done on the fly,
you end up saying,
why didn't that work?
I put loads of time into a chart.
Notice it works really well if you sit down area and saying,
low my trying to reach am my trying to achieve and why get them,
what are they interested?
One of the very clever things,
Carol companies that I profiled in the book was new rich server and you've
reached silver.
I'm a great believer in third party endorsement.
If you stand up and say,
no,
I run a wonderful business that's involved with business.
Everybody in his loves what they do.
We provide great quality product or whatever.
Everybody would say where you would say that wouldn't get,
which is fair enough because you're not going to say are going a rubbish
business.
[inaudible] was the guy who did that is jewelry businessman post.
There wasn't,
one of them famously said he just produced a joke,
jewelry and people buy it and the entire business,
what goes very shortly afterwards because everybody said,
well I,
I buy that truck jewelry and he thinks that junk.
Why do I waste my time binder?
As a general rule,
you're looking at third party adults from just where somebody says have you it's
good.
Or were you creating association and you put your very clever creates the
association.
They came up with this idea of style ambassadors.
So instead of just being June,
they start to using people like any Google and Naomi Campbell,
um,
Ronan O'gara and say,
okay,
these are people who,
who you can associated with our jewelry.
Interestingly enough,
they use linter grade.
You're the lady from Dallas.
That's interesting.
How many people actually know Linda Gray from Dallas?
Very few.
Excellent.
Did I do,
it makes my point because she was wearing,
she was history in the late eight years ago when they started using her as she
was wearing big chunky.
You read shooting.
Now she's a fabulous in her seventies at the time,
you would've given her like 52 at the most,
should have amazing and she's wearing this chunky jewelry and you look to talk.
She,
she actually isn't the type of person who wears chunky jewelry.
If she had been doing newbridge country dining at home,
here's,
here's how the posh Stein,
it probably would have sacked much more easily,
but doing chunky jewelry at her age,
even though she found this didn't seem to work,
but it did work very well with the likes of baby Hoover room.
And they only can go and what they do is they associate the people with the
product.
So if they're stylish and there they wear our product,
you should do the same.
Very interesting.
When I spoke to the lady who coordinates the brand ambassadors,
I said to that must be very difficult because I innocently assumed that if you
were an Uber and you were wearing,
you bridge that as new ritual and say,
and by the way,
sweepy either not once you were in anybody else's jury because we're paying you
shed loads of money.
So I expect to see you in you were jokingly and she said,
Oh God no.
And because nobody who follows Amy Uber will believe that.
They would know that of course you where she has her own side,
she whereas any one of a number of different things.
So when she chooses to wear newbridge we're happy that she does.
But when she chooses to wear somebody else,
we're equally happy.
And as I was very clever because it then doesn't look like we pay you to wear
this jewelry all the time.
It looks like yes you are around the ambassador when you feel like wearing it.
And she actually wore a long chain and when she announced that she was expecting
her second charge,
more love newbridge change had a match feature and she tweeted something about
the coach,
I can't remember both by guard chained by newbridge and we saw that they had no
idea she was going to do it.
They knew what she was doing,
the focus.
She was cranky that she was pregnant,
but she didn't want to say if few regiments eventually tweeted,
it was just like,
oh,
it's her.
Right.
So she tweeted that they weren't expecting it.
They sold off the chain,
they went to a second production and so on the second production as well,
the number of people who just wanted to buy that chain.
So the association from their point you work really well.
They associate with people that people want to look like or people want to
emulate.
And they follow that through with New Zealand style icons.
So they actually have all of these calls which are actually exempt down to Saint
Joe's or Mafi from that.
It's incredible.
And how old's the tones are,
but they were Audrey Hepburn's or they were,
um,
who is an AP went up as Princess Grace of Monaco and Grace Kelly.
So you ended up looking at these clothes thinking wow,
that's when people actually more today,
anybody go down for the Michael Jackson exhibition by the way.
And Michael Jackson's that close.
I mean,
you know,
the famous girls are there.
I just decided I have to go down in there.
So I have my friends cause I actually sent somebody and they'd be transfer.
But this one tiny like size age would have the giant,
he was absolutely tiny and but they,
they actually make that association and it's clever.
It's an association that started with,
or you call it,
you buy some of the product,
you've made the link.
Very,
very smart.
And they also work with Audrey Hepburn's and Grace Kelly's foundation so that
they improve whatever it is they design that they use.
This would have been the kind of thing that Grace Kelly would have used.
And so it carries her name with very,
very smart,
much simper tarred party endorsement if you like.
When I was talking about the book too,
Bobby Care on Newstalk,
uh,
he had said to me,
okay,
why don't I do,
is I choose the examples that we lose my sister,
I don't mind after you've had this in the book,
I'm happy to talk about,
so we actually talked about Jackie March and many talked about Jack Morris
Company and we actually,
I mean it's a 10 or 12 minutes interview.
So we went through the interview and we chat with myself.
This kind is crazy.
And then he'd go into his office.
The walls are paper with paper and every piece of paper has this tweet.
How many retreats?
What was the reach isn't worth doing?
Did it work?
Should we do it again?
He dates a month within an inch of his life and it just seems so strange that
it's all on paper,
right?
The walls,
but I presume it's because it's around a little bit.
Reminds them this is what we are,
this is what we do.
Did the interview [inaudible] promotion for the book?
My job was still as I was,
that was on a Saturday,
on Sunday as I was driving somewhere,
I got a text from Jack to say thanks very much for the kind words that I put my
business yesterday.
I knew whose father was in and he said,
unfortunately my father just died and somebody heard the interview on the way to
the funeral and very kind of you say such nice things.
My thought,
great.
This didn't actually text and said sorry to [inaudible] and thanks for the
comments and then I'm following Friday.
I came into the office and there's this huge box of cupcakes.
So I said,
well,
we'll ask who's sending the scope cases it us,
us,
it specifically says Ellen.
Ghanaians who sending me cupcakes and inside was enough who's a dozen cupcakes
and to Saint Jacques saying,
thank you very much for all of the comments on news talk you wouldn't believe.
How much business do you got on the back of the best regards?
Jack,
I wasn't promoting his business,
I wasn't flooding with business,
I wasn't advertising.
I would just say he's really good at what he does.
And that's a third party endorsement.
That's somebody else saying it with no ax to grind.
And that is very,
very powerful and that's something actually that you would Google to do very
easy.
You work with SMEs,
you've already gone through who they are,
you cross checked and you think they have something of value that you could
invest your time or your money or your energy it.
Um,
is there a way that you can actually say to people,
do you know what?
There is a way that you can brand,
you can say brand Google works with you so that they can take that to other
people and say,
it's not just me saying I know I'm a Google believes.
I don't want them just to leave you with that part.
There are six other hot tips in the book.
I'm happy to go through all of them if you wish,
but I might actually give you a chance to,
cause you're,
you're sitting quiet came and I'm much more comfortable where people are in and
the elderly.
So might let you ask a few questions and see what happens.
Thanks.
Great.
Thanks Alan.
That was
[inaudible]
well we jump straight into that on how
they'd like to ask.
We've got two microphones to pass around or any questions.
Are we good?
You're building up some last and confidence.
Trying to think about it.
Um,
I'd like to,
to know,
and um,
he touched on very,
very briefly,
they age,
knowing your audience and considering who exactly am I trying to reach the other
than maybe just asking yourself those really specific questions.
Is there anything else?
What,
what else should we be asking yourselves or how else can we really answer that
question?
I taped the trap that most people fall into.
Um,
we all look to each people that use the same methods that we used.
So if I read the Irish times,
I assume that everybody I want to reach for the Irish Times.
If I live on social media,
I assume it'll live on social media.
And what happens is we forget to look at the other side and say,
actually where did they,
I call it where people feed.
I attended a conference a few years back and the guy talked about chasing pages.
I don't know if you've heard this story before.
I call.
It was brilliant.
And he talked about if you chase the agents,
if you try to feed pigeons and you chased them in a park,
pigeons fly away.
Like go and stop chasing your brother.
Watch the old man who sits down at the park seat and he just keeps dropping
cones and the come to him and it's about knowing what I believe is looking for a
bread.
And I was never hassled.
They'll come to you and more often they come to you.
The more they trust you and the more that you build up their confidence with any
kind of an audience.
If your problem is that you look at them from the inside out,
you should look from the outside in.
The chances are with any business,
you actually need to use it.
They said originally when when radio was overtaking my television or television
was abandoned,
it says the death of radio.
When newspapers came in,
they said it was the debt to something else.
When social media can,
they just said,
oh,
that's it.
People will over your social media.
It's actually not true.
We did.
We did an interview at the weekend rotation,
a TV presenters course,
and we were doing mock interviews and it bounces over your thing for the
shoulders and one of the ladies that the students were just interviewing each
other withdrawals,
all of our 20 [inaudible] and the [inaudible] who was eating essentially one of
your eyes,
why are you interested in?
And she says active is,
that's the other guy,
Brandon.
So ask her about us.
Married this scream speech.
Donald Trump tweeting,
it's called loans,
all that kind of stuff.
It was,
if it was fascinating,
which one she,
since we saw Meryl Streep's speech,
you are all familiar that Meryl Streep made a speech.
Okay,
just check.
Uh,
Marilyn speeds.
Meryl Streep's speech at the Golden Globes.
Hush.
You think we should?
I don't know.
I didn't hear what was it and she said okay.
And she gave a very quick explanation and she says,
I'm Donald Trump tweeted,
you know,
the most no brace back cause in America,
whatever.
Yeah,
I can see that.
She's okay.
Well what do you think about the fact that the president elect is tweeting about
an actress and she said,
I don't know.
I haven't seen any of,
I have no idea.
I catch up on all my social media on Sunday mornings
and it was eye opening.
It was like everybody in the room was too.
Everybody had heard Meryl Streep Computer.
How could you miss it?
Because it's on a Taco from so many different angles and then her work Sunday
morning going when she caught him up and everything.
So it's looking at your audience from that point of view and saying,
if they made,
if there are so many newspaper readers,
then that's where you need to get them.
It doesn't matter that you could be all over social media.
They will find kid.
If they're social media people then were what bloggers do they actually read and
who influences them,
who they think is rubbish because they think it's brilliant.
If it's radio,
which radio stations do they listen to us?
So anything you talk to just her sorority,
you want us to different [inaudible] you choose with the Diet that you stay more
or less on the Diet that you're on a certain date.
And then if you're over a certain age group,
where do you actually go hunting for information?
Or does it come into you by email?
So it's really,
it's breaking down your audience.
I'm probably choosing a different tool for each subsection.
That's a very long,
that sounds great.
Thank you very much.
We've got a question here.
I was thinking,
uh,
first of all this we'll talk,
um,
I was thinking some sponsorships.
Um,
so I think most of us who are in an ex pat,
so not sort of Ireland.
And so when I've dug deep into the community,
as you kind of mentioned some of the examples that you had,
what would be some of the easier ways to get into a,
you're giving up a sponsorship or get in touch with people.
What would be some of the first couple of steps to getting as sponsorships to
actually find something that's functioning?
I would go the other way around them.
If you're not from Ireland,
I achieved something that was unique to you.
So it might be presented in movies or something and you think,
okay,
how have a look at the community and see where is there a community week and it
is a community week.
Is there a role in there somewhere for movies and as parks and movies we can
show Brazilian boom,
you think depends on what the connection is that you're trying to make and it
also sets you up.
You are the logical connections.
You can actually introduce yourself and say,
I'm presented.
That's why I'm passionate about presenting movies.
He never would have guessed and people would ask you all happening because
people actually got make the connection.
Unless you tell him a seat at the table,
they would say you an ex patch or whatever.
You're not various,
but the moment where you're from.
And so I would look for something that is close to your heart that you're an
expert in,
that you can offer just sponsor,
but it's more work.
It means that you need to set it up creative enrollment.
But if you do,
people will come.
When I did the first active age week,
everybody told me that I was wasting my time.
If I was looking at creating things for senior citizens,
but they were interested in was Bingo.
So like if people to gossip,
I did Bingo seven nights a week,
then you happy I've,
and I said bill to his face to systems I can face that ever played thing go or
has any desire to create big no,
no.
It's not happening.
Well,
what I want to do is I'll do one night or finger,
but I would do everything else around it.
And if nobody comes to anything,
there's my boss.
You can kick in and say,
I told you you're picking up an agent.
You were wrong.
And we did historical nights,
we did both trips.
We did mystery trip sessions to complete.
We did afternoons where people just came in and somebody who played piano and
they all signed.
We were blocked at every single standing room only at every single function and
the alternative legal as well.
But nobody said at the end of the week called a pity of Austin called Bingo.
So I think if you actually,
if you find something that you're passionate about that you can create,
even will come and it will make a association.
It also gives you a niche that nobody else has.
The other thing with sponsorship is if you come in to sponsor after somebody has
been there,
it takes a long time to lose the last sponsor's name.
So the general rule is that you should sponsor,
if you're doing a sponsorship data should be for three years and you should add
an extra two so you have a facility that nobody else can step in for the next
two you get first dibs up,
but after five you should move on back to your audience again cause after five
if you're targeting 17 year olds and 17 year old and I ate in a French 102 there
are no longer interested in the same things.
They moved on to something else.
But after five years your name stays for at least two so the next sponsor coming
in has an awful job branding their name onto whatever it is they're doing.
So I go the other words and creative with your name monitors and let them follow
you.
Hi,
my name's [inaudible],
I'm parking in sensing thing.
Google marketing solutions team.
In fact,
mine is not a question,
it's just an inspiration for you.
It was very,
very high hump them at Google's.
We tried it yet.
That's Google sales team are trying to increase our share folders from our class
media business.
But today you gave me another amazing idea why they are want to change to
increase our budget or team our clients made in Westmont.
Also we can have pay your share from our client's PR budget as well if he can
positions Google products as a PR scholarships.
It was very,
very eye opening and it was a Hutu beverage for my business.
When I turn back to my desk,
hundred percent viability tribal to meet six I will organize meetings with my
clients,
PR managers.
I'm talking about people too that they can use for their parents.
I just want you to half a percent of that business stuff.
That's all
you're right because advertising very often is part of a promotional plan so you
can do a huge amount of PR that actually gets you out there and gets your
product and your brown no,
but it gets to the stage where you say,
no,
I need to sell it,
but you will still use PR two and a half.
Part of it is the straight selling and the other is you still keep turning up
and people say,
oh,
I saw an ad for that somewhere.
So brilliant.
I mean,
I know
I brag about we can have a picture
or a story that was very inspiring.
Like,
um,
my father was probably the Milkman didn't realize the effects that the
sponsorship has.
So my question is,
if the SME is decides to do a PR investments,
what kind of advice can you give?
Defining what success is,
it depends on what you're actually trying to achieve.
Um,
so what's about to shoot is best at is creating name awareness.
If you look at any of the great sponsorships they started because people were
moving into new markets or they had changed their name.
So the company was no longer and was one thing,
it was no longer something else.
Um,
when who sponsored the first cycle race around artists wants a Toyota and they
sponsored it because it's a car company,
it doesn't make sense in the car company responds to recycling.
Raisa was at the time when I'm Steven Roach and all of those guys were winning
medals.
But it was because the toilet we're used to be called was the term used to be
called data and people didn't know the brand.
So the whole idea was if you create an awareness of the brand,
people say,
I've heard it here at what's the story?
It opens the door a bit.
Or what sponsorship is best at is creating brand awareness.
So if you are an SME and you're trying to make people conscious of the fact that
you are around,
sponsorship is very good at it.
But you need to do your before and after.
Most people would tell you,
if you ask people in Google,
how many people have heard of Google,
Google is probably a bad example.
They go,
well,
you know,
is there anybody less than the world's?
A couple of people who are as I believe,
I haven't heard this yet,
but you know everybody,
every SME,
just the same thing they say we,
they were very well known and it is true within your own circle.
So if it's within a public relations circle but then it circle it probably are
very well know,
but they're not very well known to a wider world.
So if you're sponsoring within the community,
because you just want the community to know who you are,
what you do,
you're on their doorstep and they should really be thinking of you in terms of
maybe few through employment the door and just saying to people,
they're good guys and they're up there and they're doing great work.
Then it will work very well for that project.
Evil,
you need research in advance and research afterwards.
It doesn't have to be hugely scientific.
You can,
so long as you structure the questions,
you probably know this but so long as you structure the questions so that
they're open enough and people don't know what the answer is because if you ask
people,
do you think Google is wonderful?
They'd say,
yes,
I do.
They think of as awful.
That's a problem.
If you say,
what do you think of Google?
You get an understand sir,
because you haven't told them what it is you expect.
You can do it by,
if it's a community thing,
you can send people out into the community saying,
have you ever heard of this organization idea of what they do?
Who's in the building of the car there and you you find out a loan for what you
do is you go back and you do the same research afterwards.
So I don't expect that everybody will suddenly say,
oh my God more herbage.
But if you get like a 5% increase,
that's cool.
You're moving in the right direction.
And again,
it's targeted to your audience or the people who stopped to ask questions of,
we sent a group of,
I'm sorry,
it's very long winded answer.
Well we sent a group,
I was with one stage and we were training journalists and I sent them out to do
interviews with people and I said,
now be sure you don't get all the same people.
So don't ask some people who look like you.
Stop.
Even across a mix of age groups,
stock men and women do everything from like 17 to 77 or something.
And I'm trying to make something,
make some kind of note about middle aged,
senior person,
younger person.
So when you come back,
you can say,
I interviewed,
cause it was for radio,
so I interviewed 10 people.
Four of them would have been under 25 meals were over 55 and the guys actually
went to,
and there were Italian and Italians in the room.
They have a whole other way of doing things so that he wouldn't have,
he said,
hello,
I'm John Uncle.
So ks you're telling me how old are you?
And they said,
I parked six to half.
I'm followed you.
Chuck couldn't believe it.
If an Irish person did it,
then I picked you up off the ground.
But it's,
it's the audience you're trying to reach.
So if you target the age group as well,
carefully,
but that also means watching who you send them to send out a young person,
target older people that will do it as well.
Send up an older person is at the same age group stopping in.
You'd get more honest answers.
I'm just wondering,
the four year old,
did you know what audience you're targeting or did that come along when you are
writing?
How did you decide your audience that you're targeting?
What happened was,
this is my second book,
my book,
the first book that I would have felt loving relationship with practical
approach.
Everybody in our interest studies to be off,
so we're effective oncologist.
It's an academic text it eight gigs and it's a doorstop but 600 pages or
something.
I actually thought that I would be revising that we're not doing anything else
with PR and I had met with Mercier press who published the book and I actually
met with the advise clients and they said I had sent them the pitch and they
came back and said,
actually we would be interested,
you know,
we meet you and we will be interested in publishing to go for the client.
And I said,
that's fine.
I really appreciate you having it off.
Whereas should we go with the group?
Who else should publish it?
At the end of the conversation she said,
you never thought to write another book on public relations.
You're settled this year unless you both,
to answer your question,
I know cause I've kind of covered everybody who studies the subject and she said
that I said,
Oh yeah,
I looked at,
I have no sense.
They said yes to all the things that interest me and then give out yards and say
why did I decide to do who scheduled this need?
But I actually felt great idea and it was completely different because I central
want to do is I know the things that SMBs use,
but it gave me an opportunity to go as another for companies in that sector
because we all look at the larger homes.
So it was looking at smaller companies and see how they're using the web and how
you use them as case studies.
So the audience almost spend the seven because that was the way to request came.
Okay.
Thank you.
I was thinking,
but if the sponsorship and the fact that it's very good for the brand awareness
that it's needed in a very initial phase of the business,
what happens when you do something bad with this spiritual?
So you basically a compromise your reputation in a very initial phase.
So,
uh,
do you have an example of good,
good example of how some business could have recovered from a bed usage of
sponsorship?
It's very interested.
She has a reputation.
Reputation takes a lifetime to build on a purchase seconds.
Two things I was worried about.
If it said,
if you think that everything you do will be public email and we'll be very
careful about what to do.
And that's about reputation because you lose reputation very easily.
People are very stupid things with reputation.
Probably one of the best examples was the,
I've kind of got the name of the company.
It wasn't a the company.
Do you remember when there was no going back 25 years or more?
The company where the guy was actually injecting Tyler tablets in the states
it was,
I just remember the random dude he was injecting Sinai [inaudible].
Anyway,
it made people very nervous about actually using the product and they had a
great reputation.
They were very well known and what they did was,
and most people will be more cognitive of crazy at the time,
what they did was they withdrew all department from the shells and they put
messages are very worse.
They do not use our product.
If you have it at home,
bring it back.
We'll give you a full refund for God's sake,
don't they?
Any tablets,
we don't know what's going on.
You don't want anybody to die because they take them,
I think to people in New York and we don't know what's happened.
Everybody said,
you know,
great move from your point of view.
Obviously they care about the customers.
They're going to have nothing left to come back to it because we've left this
gap and the competitors will take it over and when they came back,
they came back with that foil seal and they said,
so now we've made it an extra stage.
Now you will know if anybody has tampered with these cabinets,
you check seal should be broken before foliage will be attacked.
It was very clever and they recovered market share and curriculum because people
actually said they care about,
they did an example,
it wasn't got it very wrong.
Michelle in states one,
they the all have damage and they sent over and the prayer they got it wrong was
from minute one.
They sent over an English chief executive,
uh,
an English pure person a or you paid your person and a UK lawyer.
So he had you in this state to wherever he looks like this and saw like one of
the door,
okay,
do we have to listen the whole thing up and you get aloe,
I'm the chief executive and I'm over here in America and I've got to solve it,
have color.
The PR person,
I'm over here with just common sense says a prospective country that you're in
that that's going to reputation.
If you actually respect your customers and that country,
you get somebody with local eyes and ears on the ground.
You get somebody who's American who says,
this is how it works and this is just two English.
This is how people will interpret what you're saying and their reputation stuff
massively.
I'm not sure that the covered yet.
And you'll find an awful lot of companies on the,
or the reputation is severity damage.
They actually come speaking meaning company because the research says you won't
walk off with people,
will is associated with the disaster.
Hmm.
So that they have no option.
But it's a good example of if you don't get it right,
how much damage you can do.
That's the other side.
Fantastic.
Thank you so much.
I love it.
That was amazing.
Sometimes fantastic stories.
And I know there are a few more questions that we don't have time to get around
to,
but you have different ways that we can contact you that you've already shared
with me so I can share them as with everyone else.
So thank you again for being our first home.
Yeah.
And you did say everybody chases out at 12 noon.